Good afternoon.
Thank you everyone for attending our Clinical
Trial Mini Symposium four, Focus on ctDNA.
As you'll see this afternoon, we have a collection of a number
of very exciting
and innovative clinical trials that are utilizing
ctDNA in a number of creative ways, both to
understand treatment response, patient selection,
and integration as a predictive biomarkers in a number
of areas.
And
really a great opportunity to understand
and review the technologies being utilized, but more importantly, how we're
applying them into the application of patient care.
So with that, we'll start with our first presenter,
Dr. Yanrong Jiang will be presenting
on neoadjuvant pembrolizumab stratified by tumor mutation burden
and high-risk stage two, three deficient mismatch repair or
MSI-high colorectal cancer. The
NeoPRISM-CRC study. This is looking at
perioperative ultrasensitive ctDNA monitoring and
tumor-infiltrating TCR repertoire for treatment response
prediction. Dr. Jiang.
Thank you very much for the kind introduction.
On behalf of my collaborators and co-authors, we're very grateful for the
opportunity to present the ctDNA analysis and the T-cell repertoire
analysis, as well as the updated survival outcomes from the NeoPRISM
colorectal trial.
These are my disclosures.
Approximately 15% of colorectal cancers harbor mismatch repair
deficiency, and these are characterized by high tumor mutation burden as
well as sensitivity to immune checkpoint blockade.
The current standard of care is surgery plus or minus adjuvant
chemotherapy. However, despite this, 20 to
40% of the patients relapse within the first three years.
There's been a number of studies using neoadjuvant immunotherapy in this
space that have shown promising results, both in downstaging the disease and
improving survival outcomes.
One of the studies is the NeoPRISM colorectal trial, which
investigated neoadjuvant pembrolizumab in patients with high-risk
stage two or stage three MMRd colorectal cancers in the
UK.
In total, we enrolled 32 patients, and 31 of whom went on to receive
up to three cycles of pembrolizumab.
All eligible patients proceeded to surgery plus or minus adjuvant
chemotherapy.
The critical questions still remain in this field regarding optimal
immunotherapy regimen and duration, and we've integrated a
comprehensive translational program in our study to try to address some of these
questions.
First of all, we show that nine weeks of neoadjuvant pembrolizumab achieved
59% pathological complete response in our patients with
no significant safety signals. In addition, more than half of the
patients had high-grade T4 tumors, and a third of the
patients had Lynch syndrome.
Here I'll be presenting the perioperative ctDNA profiling using the Next Personal
assay as well as the T-cell receptor profiling data.
Longitudinal plasma samples were collected at baseline throughout
treatment before each cycle of pembrolizumab preoperatively and
postoperatively. In addition, we collected follow-up samples between
three to 36 months. Baseline tumor biopsies
underwent whole genome sequencing to help design our personalized assay as well as
T-cell receptor profiling. Treatment response was defined by
histopathological assessment of the resected primary tumor
and the associated lymph nodes.
ctDNA analysis was performed using the Next Personal assay, which
is a whole genome sequencing-based tumor-informed panel
tracking up to 1,400 variants in the samples.
By targeting both coding and non-coding regions, we were able to cover a much
broader range than exome-only techniques.
In addition, background suppression meant that we could go down to median limit of
detection of one to three parts per million using only four milliliters of
plasma.
In total, we analyzed 227 samples in 25
eligible patients, and 97 of these were in the pre-surgery time period.
We detected ctDNA in 100% of the patients at baseline,
and a quarter of these occurred in the ultrasensitive region of below 100
ppm.
ctDNA detection ranged from one to nearly
60,000 ppm.
This bar chart summarizes the percentage of patients who cleared their
ctDNA throughout the treatment cycles.
At the pre-cycle two time point, 24% of the patients have cleared their
ctDNA.
At the pre-surgery time point after three cycles of treatment,
58% of the patients have cleared.
And at the post-surgery time point, which was four to five weeks post-surgery, all
of the patients had cleared their ctDNA.
We then looked at the ctDNA kinetic profiles in our cohort, and the
ctDNA clearance is represented by the logarithmic scale on the y-axis
in these plots, and three distinct patterns emerged.
First, there was a group of patients who rapidly and completely
cleared their ctDNA after one cycle of treatment, and this
group of super molecular responders all achieved pathological complete response.
Secondly, there was a group of dynamic molecular responders who had rapid
reduction of ctDNA levels to less than 100
ppm pre-surgery, and 80% of these patients achieved
PCRAnd finally, there was a group of patients who had
stable or rising ctDNA levels, and in this group of poor molecular
responders, none of the patients cleared their ctDNA.
Importantly, ctDNA kinetics in our study was irrespective of
patients' radiological stage, histology, age, sex,
Lynch syndrome status, or other standard clinical parameters.
We then asked how this could be applied to real-time clinical practice
decision-making, and we propose that in the super molecular responders,
these patients could be considered for non-operative management.
The dynamic molecular responders could be considered for continuing
immunotherapy and/or operate. And the poor
molecular responders, we recommend operating or considering treatment
intensification in this group.
We also assess ctDNA as a post-operative
surveillance MRD tool.
And currently, we have a median follow-up of nearly 33 months, and no
patients have relapsed so far. Two of our patients have had CAPOX
adjuvant chemotherapy, but without prior knowledge of their ctDNA status.
And
this swimmer plot shows the plasma samples that we have processed
up to 24 months of follow-up in these patients.
And as we can see, the ctDNA surveillance demonstrated 100%
specificity with no false positives in the study and
100% negative prediction value. And so in our study,
undetectable post-operative ctDNA accurately predicted
relapse-free status.
We then asked whether we could find any biomarkers that could predict patients'
response before they start immunotherapy treatment.
In other tumor types, T cell receptor sequencing metrics have been
assessed as a biomarker. In particular, large T cell clonal
expansion is associated with high immunogenicity and a
favorable response to immunotherapy.
And therefore, we performed RNA-based targeted TCR
profiling of our baseline tumor biopsies on 31
eligible baseline tumors using a technique called Fume TCR-Seq.
In particular, we focused on a group of expanded large clones and compared these
across the treatment groups. And as we can see from the violin plot, the
patients who went on to achieve complete pathological response had
more expanded large clones than those who did not.
And this suggests that responders harbored pre-existing
poised anti-tumor T cells, which is unleashed by pembrolizumab's
mechanism of action. And this also provides a mechanistic explanation for
the rapid ctDNA reduction in our molecular responders.
We then asked what the potential predictive performance might be to
integrate these two approaches, and this is shown by the Bayesian model on
the left of the slide.
On the x-axis is the TCR clonal expansion, and on the y-axis
is the ctDNA reduction.
Each individual dot represents a patient in our cohort, and the
contours represent the probability of achieving complete pathological
response. And as we can see, patients who had strong TCR clonal
expansion and who cleared their ctDNA rapidly
clustered in the region of high probability of
achieving a response. And patients who had low TCR
clonal expansion and who cleared their ctDNA slowly clustered in
this region of low probability of response.
And so dynamic ctDNA clearance adds a strong discrimination layer beyond
TCR alone, separating patients with similar immune profiles
into distinct confidence regions of achieving response.
And we propose that this could possibly be used as a tool for real-time clinical
decision making in the future.
In summary, here are the key translational findings from our study.
First of all, ctDNA was detected in 100% of our
patients, with 24% of these detections in the ultrasensitive
range of less than 100 ppm.
In addition, ctDNA had 100% longitudinal
post-operative specificity and negative prediction value for relapse.
100% of the super molecular responders achieved complete
pathological response, while poor molecular responders did not.
In terms of the immune profiling, tumor T cell receptor clonality may predict
patients who will have an excellent response prior to their first
cycle of immunotherapy.
In addition, a combined model incorporating both TCR and ctDNA
clearance predicts individual patient response.
Here are the key clinical implications
from our trial. Nine weeks of pre-operative single agent pembrolizumab
in DMMR high risk stage two or stage three colorectal cancers
results in significant disease downstaging with 59%
PCR. There were no new adverse safety signals, and
with a median follow-up of nearly 33 months, there was no disease relapse.
These are the points that are potentially practice changing.
Early ctDNA clearance may allow for selection of super responders to single
agent immunotherapy for non-operative management.
In addition, post-operative ctDNA clearance allows for selective requirement
of adjuvant therapies.
Baseline TCR profiling has the potential to predict patient response
even before beginning the first cycle of immunotherapy treatment.
And finally, we propose that early adoption of these approaches into future
prospective, adaptive, biomarker-informed clinical trials.
Thank you. And first of all, we'd like to thank all our patients and their families
for contributing to the clinical trial.
We'd like to thank all our clinical colleagues from across the UK, as well as our
scientific collaborators, in particular Personalis.
And finally, we'd like to thank MSD for funding the trial and UCL for sponsoring
the trial. Thank you very much.
Okay. We'll open this up for questions,
discussion. So please, those in the room, you can come up to the microphone and
just identify yourself by name
and institution prior to your question.
We also have polling and questions available
online,
so please make use of your app to send in
questions.
So maybe I can start with one while
we're
getting additional input here. So one of the striking
things is certainly wonderful sensitivity of the
assay and ability to kind of segregate nicely into different
groups. I was struck by the fact that in your responding
population,
even those that hadn't fully cleared ctDNA looked like the vast
majority of those were still continuing to trend downward on
ctDNA.
Can you maybe extrapolate a little bit related to
the time on treatment and whether
you can envision some future state where we could be monitoring patients by
ctDNA instead of taking them to surgery?
Yeah. Thank you very much for the excellent question.
So in our data, we saw two
different
ctDNA clearance patterns. The first one was the super molecular responders
who cleared really very quickly after the first cycle of treatment.
And we propose that in these patients who clear their ctDNA very
rapidly, that these patients could be considered for non-operative
approaches. Now, interestingly, the second group of dynamic
responders who still cleared the vast majority of their ctDNA,
to the sort of less than 100 PPM, which is in the ultrasensitive range,
these patients, we propose we could repeat their ctDNA testing,
maybe continue in treatment and sort of see how they would do with
further testing.
Thank you. Question.
Thank you.
It was a great presentation.
Just a quick question. You said clonal expansion
can be used as a biomarker, so how do you propose we
can test the clonal expansion?
Yeah, what stage will it be useful? Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you very much for the question.
So yeah, so that relates to the T cell repertoire profiling, which
we, in this study, we performed on the baseline tumor
biopsies, and that's really a tool to see whether we could find a
biomarker that could predict response before on-treatment monitoring
with ctDNA. So we did that
on the baseline tumor biopsies as a
tool to predict which patients might respond to treatment with
ongoing on-treatment monitoring.
One at a time. Thank you. Just have you introduce yourself before the question.
Andy Futrell, MD Anderson. Since you have whole genome sequencing on
these three different buckets, are you going back and looking in the buckets now
and exploring other aspects of genome sequencing?
Not only sort of the mutations themselves, but levels of sub
clonality, copy number changes, whole genome doubling.
So you have the ability to sort of tease these apart with that data now.
Thank you very much for the question.
That's one of the great things about having the whole genome sequencing data as
well, that these are some of the further things that we would definitely like to
look into in the future, again, as exploratory biomarkers of
response.
Bria.
Okay. Thank you very much, Dr. Jiang.
Thank you very much.
I'll turn it over to my co-chair to introduce himself and our next speaker.
Thank you very much. Yeah, that was so excellent.
Now we're going to move on. So I'm Adil Chaudhry.
I'm a physician scientist at the Mayo Clinic, and my lab focuses on
ctDNA liquid biopsy technologies.
Brings me great pleasure to introduce our next speaker, Julia
Foldy, and she'll be presenting on early findings from
MONITOR-BREAST, ctDNA dynamics during neoadjuvant therapy
using an ultrasensitive MRD assay. Julia, the floor is yours.
Thank you very much for that introduction.
On behalf of my co-investigators, I'm delighted to present here
early findings from the MONITOR-BREAST study.
Here are my disclosures. I have no financial relationships with Myriad
Genetics to disclose.
So in breast oncology, pathologic response to
neoadjuvant therapy has been used as a risk stratification tool,
particularly in those patients with HER2 positive and triple negative
breast cancers.
As seen here in a representative Kaplan-Meier
plot from the I-SPY 2 study,
increasing residual cancer burden, or RCB index, which is a
marker of poor tumor response to neoadjuvant therapy, is
associated with worse distant relapse-free survival
in patients with early stage breast cancers.
More recently, ctDNA positivity, both at
diagnosis and post neoadjuvant therapy, have been shown to
be independent predictors of metastatic recurrence,
as well as ctDNA clearance and negativity
being associated with favorable long-term outcomes in
multiple different studies using different MRD assays.
The plot from the I-SPY 2 study shows that for the
same RCB index, patients with negative ctDNA after
neoadjuvant therapy have significantly improved long-term outcomes
compared to patients with the same RCB index, but positive ctDNA.
Importantly, in patients who do not achieve a PCR but
have negative ctDNA after neoadjuvant therapy, shown both in the
PredictDNA and NSABP B-59
studies, these patients have nearly as good long-term outcomes as
patients who achieve a path CR after neoadjuvant
therapy.A lot of these earlier studies have
used less sensitive MRD assays
and sparse sampling that may have missed critical time points.
Therefore, the aim of the MONITOR-Breast study's neoadjuvant cohort
was to prospectively evaluate the association between ctDNA
dynamics and pathologic response across breast cancer
subtypes.
The population of this study included patients with all breast cancer
subtypes, early stages one, two, and three, receiving
real-world treatment regimens.
We used an ultrasensitive whole-genome sequencing-based assay that
tracked up to 1,000 individualized variants per patient,
detecting ctDNA down to levels under 100
ppm.
We also used dense sampling in this study, including a
diagnosis at each cycle of neoadjuvant
therapy, the post-neoadjuvant therapy time point, surgery,
and the post-op time point.
This consort diagram here shows our enrollment.
A total of 424 patients were enrolled.
A subset of them are in a separate adjuvant cohort who are
currently being followed. In this particular neoadjuvant
study, 132 patients were enrolled.
120 of them had successful panel creation,
representing a 91% success rate. And here I'm
presenting data on 113 patients who had at least
three plasma samples available for analysis.
All of these patients were female with a median age of 56 years,
representing all subtypes and early stages of breast cancer.
Most had ductal cancers and single primary tumors,
and just over half of them had node-negative disease.
A total of 844 plasma samples were analyzed for a
median of nine time points per patient.
In terms of treatment, all patients received chemotherapy,
42% received immunotherapy, and 36% received
HER2-targeted therapy.
This pie chart here shows the distribution of receptor subtypes.
40% of patients had triple-negative, and 36%
had HER2-positive breast cancers, while the remaining
25% had hormone receptor-positive, HER2-negative breast cancers.
The stage distribution shown here reveals that
most patients had stage two cancers, while there was an enrichment
of stage three cancers in the hormone receptor-positive, HER2-negative
subgroup.
This slide shows baseline ctDNA detection rates.
In all patients, 91% had detectable
ctDNA at baseline, which increased with disease burden by
stage, clinical T stage, and nodal status.
When broken down by breast cancer subtype, we can see that
100% of those patients with hormone receptor-positive, HER2-negative
disease had detectable ctDNA at baseline, and the highest
median tumor fraction was detected in those with triple-negative breast cancers.
Importantly, 20% of all samples were detected in the ultrasensitive
range under 100 ppm.
Now to look at ctDNA dynamics and pathologic response.
This spider plot here shows four different time points:
baseline, the last neoadjuvant therapy time
point available for each patient, the post-neoadjuvant time point, and the
post-op time point. And you can see these different patterns
between patients who had residual disease versus those with PCR.
A different way of looking at this is the proportion of patients
who had ctDNA positivity in orange or
ctDNA negative assays in blue at
these four different time points based on whether they had residual disease
versus a past CR.
The takeaway from this data is that all 47 patients who
achieved PCR had ctDNA negative status at the
post-neoadjuvant time point for 100%
specificity. Conversely, 32% of patients
who had residual disease were ctDNA positive at the post-neoadjuvant
time point. This is in contrast to earlier studies with
less sensitive assays, which showed this to be in the range of 14% to
20%.
Overall, 67% of samples were in the ultrasensitive range.
And in patients who had a post-neoadjuvant therapy time point where they were
ctDNA positive had a 43 times higher
chance of being ctDNA positive after surgery.
CtDNA dynamics yielded distinct patterns based on
breast cancer subtype.
This shows here that patients who had hormone receptor-positive,
HER2-negative disease shown in orange, cleared their
ctDNA later than patients with triple-negative and HER2
positive disease.
Triple negative patients,
within 45 days, 90% of them cleared their
ctDNA, whereas in hormone receptor-positive subset,
these patients required 16 weeks to capture 90% of
clearances. The timing of clearance alone, however, did not
predict PCR, but sustained negativity did.
So we observed three different patterns of clearance.
The first one was sustained MRD negativity,
representing 76% of all patients.
The remaining were split equally between those who were persistently
MRD positive versus those who had intermittent MRD
positivity. And you can see here the PCR rates for each
group being 63% for those with sustained
MRD negative assays versus
0% and 7% for the persistently MRD positive and
intermittently positive population,
respectively.To dive deeper into these three
separate patterns.
This shows those patients who had sustained
ctDNA clearance. You can see here that the timing was quite
different for individual patients.
But what was important is that these patients continued neoadjuvant
therapy for an average of 119 days after
clearance with undetectable ctDNA.
A subset of these patients also had RCB data available, and
we can see here that very few patients had RCB3
residual disease in this group.
Post-op ctDNA was available for a subset of patients, as
this is an ongoing study, and two out of 69
patients had a post-op positive ctDNA.
Importantly, 63% of sustained clearers achieved a
PCR versus 4% in those patients in the
persistent and intermittent groups.
To look at these two groups in more detail, in red here are the
patients who had persistently positive ctDNA, while
in orange are those who had intermittent ctDNA positivity.
100% of patients in the persistently positive
group had residual disease and all had RCB2 or
3 category residual disease.
Of the nine patients who had a post-op time point assay available,
six of them remained ctDNA positive at the first post-operative
visit.
Of the patients who had intermittently positive MRD assays,
93% had residual disease at surgery.
And interestingly, when MRD positivity re-emerged in these
patients, often it was seen under 20
ppm, and so this is only visible with really sensitive
assays and frequent
time points.
So additional sampling identifies more patients who are at risk for
residual disease.
In summary, frequent ultrasensitive MRD testing
reveals response patterns not visible with sparse sampling.
We see different patterns and opportunities for treatment
optimization. The majority of patients who had
sustained MRD clearance, and often early during neoadjuvant therapy,
may have opportunities for therapy de-escalation.
Conversely, the patients who had persistent or intermittent MRD
positivity,
most of them had residual disease, and this might be a
population where we can think about escalation of treatment.
Importantly, frequent testing identified 64% more patients
who were at risk for residual disease versus testing only at the
post-neoadjuvant time point. Post-neoadjuvant
ctDNA was significantly associated with pathologic
response as well as post-operative ctDNA.
Long-term survival outcomes are not yet available as study follow-up is
ongoing.
And future MRD-guided prospective trials should determine whether acting on these
response patterns have utility to meaningfully change outcomes
beyond our standard approaches.
And with that, I would like to thank everyone for their attention and thank
all of the patients who participated in our study, their families and clinicians
for their support, and all of the sites across the United States
and in Japan who participated in this study. Thank you very much.
Thank you very much, Julia. That was truly excellent.
Any questions from the audience?
Maybe I'll start with one. So I think you
really demonstrated the power of both ultrasensitive detection
technologies and also the importance of serial sampling.
But kind of one thing that struck me is that
many of these patients who have
residual disease detectable remain negative even with
ultrasensitive testing and even with serial testing.
So
is there something beyond even ppm
detection limits in order to capture these patients?
And how close are we truly to being able to
de-escalate based off of ctDNA MRD?
Yeah. So that's an excellent question.
I think we know that
MRD positivity has a clear
predictable consequence, but we don't always know what a negative test
means. And
we're seeing this with these ultrasensitive assays from multiple
studies, so perhaps it's not the sensitivity
that really matters. We don't really know
whether it's going to be the pathologic response
or
the ctDNA that's going to tell us more information, although we're starting to get
more and more information about that, seeing from multiple studies
now that even in patients who have residual disease, if they're MRD
negative at the end of neoadjuvant therapy, they have excellent
long-term outcomes, and then perhaps that's what is going to determine
our next steps in treatment.
Thank you.
I can ask one more.
So you
demonstrated, as mentioned, really the value of the dense sampling
in the context of this clinical trial.
As the field moves forward to larger studies,
is there a single time point or time points that you would recommend
that future studies should utilize?
So I think
what this study really illustrates, like you mentioned, is that
more time points provide more information.
And one thing that we all have to think about is whether this is feasible to
do in routine practice, right? Is it feasible toTo
assay at every single
cycle. And the answer is probably not going to be
feasible.
But we did see in this study that the single post-neoadjuvent time point is
probably not enough to give us all of the information needed.
I think we don't have the data to say which time
point is most important.
And we saw that even in patients who cleared early but then
re-emerged at ultra-sensitive levels, that
all by itself predicted residual disease.
So I can't answer that question because we don't have the data, but I think
that
doing these frequent assays is going to be important as much
as it's feasible.
Please.
Maria Belic from Pittsburgh. A very nice presentation, Julia.
Can you comment on any differences in terms of biology of the
disease and ctDNA dynamics?
So we don't have all of the data broken down yet by
subtype of breast cancer. But because we have the whole genome sequencing
data, that will be used for additional
exploratory
experiments and trying to get a little bit more
data beyond just the receptor subtypes, but getting more into
molecular subtypes and additional
data on that.
Well, thank you very much. I'll now turn it back over to my co-chair, Dr.
Kopetz.
Thank you.
Thank you. Our next presenter
is Dr.
Ranjan Upadhyay. He's presenting a Phase
2 study of adjuvant PD-1 blockade with endocrine
therapy in hormone receptor-positive and inflammatory breast cancer:
circulating biomarkers and molecular correlates of clinical outcomes.
Thank you, Dr. Kopetz, for the introduction, and thank you to the
organizers for the opportunity to be able to present today at this
session. So we were set up pretty nicely by Julia at the
prior talk,
but we're going to focus a little bit more on the
higher risk disease entities and in the adjuvant setting here.
So I have no disclosures. So what is inflammatory
breast cancer? It accounts for about 2% to 4% of all breast cancers,
and by more modern data suggests that this is more at the higher end of that
spectrum and increasing. But more importantly, it accounts for a higher
proportion of breast cancer mortality due to its high-risk disease
biology.
It's diagnosed clinically by the parameters that you see here.
But also we know that it's a molecularly distinct and
microenvironmentally distinct disease entity,
leading to
the high-risk disease
outcomes that we're seeing.
So here are some retrospective data showing the differences between
IBC and non-IBC. It's important to note that a diagnosis of
IBC results in automatic upstaging of your breast cancer to
Stage 3. So even in a localized setting, you are a
Stage 3 patient. And if you look specifically in this setting and
you compare the IBC versus non-IBC patients at historical data, you can see
the outcomes are quite disparate with
breast cancer specific survival in one study being less than five years
compared to 13 years in the non-IBC setting.
Now, this has improved with more modern therapies over the last 10 to 15
years, but the differences are still quite striking,
highlighting a really high unmet need.
Here we're showing a comparison of Stage 3 IBC to Stage 4
non-IBC. And what you'll note here is that the natural history of this
disease early on in the first few years mirrors each other.
Suggesting that even in the localized setting, that this is really a systemic
disease requiring systemic therapies for control.
Hormone receptor-positive, HER2-negative IBC accounts for about
30% to 40%
of the entire group. And what I wanted to highlight here is that
historically, the two-year disease-free survival for this particular subtype
has been around 60%, and this was around 2014.
So that's improved by a couple of ticks with more modern therapies, but
it remains a challenging disease entity.
So we have reason to believe that targeting the tumor microenvironment would be
particularly fruitful in IBC. We know that it's
enriched for many different immunosuppressive populations, particularly myeloid
cells,
vascular aberrations, as well as fibroblasts that act on both
innate and adaptive immunity to restrain
the
tumor control. So there's rationale to think that
immunotherapy for this particular disease would work well.
And there's data to support this in the high-risk hormone receptor-positive
disease setting. This was published last year showing that
neoadjuvently blocking PD-1 blockade can increase
the instance of pathological complete response and reduce disease burden at the
time of surgery.
So our hypothesis is that pembrolizumab would improve
disease-free survival for patients with hormone receptor-positive IBC.
These are patients who underwent neoadjuvent systemic therapy
and radiation,
and who have residual disease at the time of surgery.
So this is our trial schema. Patients were enrolled, like I said, after local
therapy as well and were planned for treatment every
three weeks for a duration of two years.
We treated 31 patients on this trial, and a subgroup of them were
available for correlative analyses that I'm going to get
into.Importantly,
71% of these patients were RCB3,
really
validating the fact that IBC in general is a very hard to treat disease.
So if you look at our top-line results with
adjuvant PD-1 blockade plus endocrine therapy, we found
a two-year disease-free survival of about 71%,
improving on our historical benchmark of about 60%,
with a median follow-up of 48 months.
We had a median DFS of 4.2 years
and a two-year OS of 90%.
Now, to
understand the determinants of a response, we had a handful of patients in which we
had paired tumor and nodal tissue that we can send for
sequencing, in which we did copy number analysis as well as somatic
mutation analysis. And what we found,
one of our striking results, is that of these six patients, the two that
had an ongoing durable disease-free survival
actually had a lower maximum variant allele frequency detected in their nodal
tissue, suggesting this could be a potential surrogate for metastatic
risk and response to checkpoint blockade.
We did do some clonal analysis to see the evolution of these tumor
clones from the primary tumor site to the lymph node.
Now, this is a very small N, and we didn't find any consistent patterns
in clonal expansion or contraction.
I've highlighted some clones there that expanded from the primary site to the lymph
node and some genes of interest that were altered.
What we did find was that
in chromosome 14, especially of the two patients who responded
durably, that we found deletions in the area of the
immunoglobulin heavy locus,
really suggesting that there may be some B cell biology that's contributing to
the response to checkpoint blockade.
And this is interesting because there's, for the past few years now, a lot of
pre-clinical and primary patient data suggesting that these B
T cell interactions in the lymph node are quite important
for responses across several solid tumor types.
So we were able to,
in partnership with our partners at Myriad, perform
longitudinal sampling of 19 patients whom we were
able to generate a panel
for MRD monitoring.
This incorporated up to 1,000 patient-specific variants
in the panel across all patients I've shown there.
If you look at the swimmer plot, you can see that
most of our patients were undetectable for the duration
of their therapy. Those are the green dots there in the bottom half of the
figure. And you can see that those patients were enriched for ongoing
responses. The one in blue are the ones that have no progression.
The few patients that did progress
typically had to end their treatment early due to adverse events, and so they
were taken off trial, and we weren't able to actually assess their
ctDNA at later time points.
The few patients that are positive,
we've
generated figures with more granular data here.
We, similar to prior presentations, found different patterns of
response.
We have patients who are positive at the post-surgical baseline
that had a very short interval to clinical progression marked by the yellow
lines, up to one to six months. One particular patient, patient
11, had actually an interval of about 18 months, suggesting that a
potential role in the PD-1 therapy in
exerting some sort of disease
control. We had a second pattern emerge
in which patients were positive at baseline post-surgically and then showed
signs of response to PD-1 blockade.
This was
importantly at the ultrasensitive range highlighted in gray here,
below 100 parts per million. One particular patient had an
ongoing response. Another recurred molecularly about
a year later and clinically at 22 months.
Finally, we had a third pattern in which we had negative ctDNA post-surgically
and then molecular recurrence followed by clinical recurrence
later on. And importantly, in patient six, we were able to have a lead time to
clinical progression of about 15 months.
As you'd expect, the ctDNA positivity was highly prognostic, both
at baseline and at end of treatment.
What I want to highlight here is that 100% of
patients who are negative at the end of treatment
were
disease-free at the two-year mark,
suggesting this could be a really powerful way to risk stratify these high-risk
patients.
So in summary, I showed that checkpoint blockade plus endocrine
therapy in high-risk IBC hormone receptor-positive
disease is a viable strategy. We ended up uncovering about a
70% disease-free survival at two years, which is improvement
over
prior historical data.
We found patterns of copy number variation between the primary metastatic
sites that suggest some sort of immune selection pressure.
We also have some peripheral immune profile that I didn't present today showing
that certain subsets of immune cells in the periphery can also
correlate with these responses. Our ultrasensitive
ctDNA preceded radiographic relapse by up to 15
months and correlated with shorter disease-free survival,
and ctDNA negativity at the end of treatment was associated with
100% disease-free survival at 24 months, which is
remarkable for a disease entity like IBC.
So with that, I'd like to thank Bora Lim, who led the study,
the MD Anderson IBC team who
carried out the study.Merck for sponsoring the study and our partners at Myriad
for doing the ctDNA work. Thank you to the patients and their families, and I'd
love to take your questions.
Okay, open for questions.
Just a reminder, we also have questions available online if you'd
like through your app or of course, coming up
here.
So maybe a
question about the sequencing and time
points. If you were to design the new study
to follow up on this result and
the sequencing, what are the most critical time points that you'd like to
incorporate
your ctDNA monitoring?
Yeah, that's a great question.
I think it's unclear for IBC because like I said, I think it is a
systemic disease. The more time points we have, the more guidance we
can have for how to manage it.
In this study, we didn't have any preoperative
ctDNA
levels to really compare how much of the disease burden
we're actually taking away with the multimodal therapy
that's
standard of care for IBC.
And so I think that would be a really important
thing to incorporate at future trials.
What's really interesting is
we think that perhaps the immune
pressures that we're
exerting with our checkpoint blockade may be restraining the
release of ctDNA at these lymph nodes, and we're hoping to explore those
questions further with spatial profiling, which will be really helpful in
future trials.
Very interesting indeed. I have a quick question as well.
Tell us about what you think is happening in the IGH locus.
How is that
dictating kind of-- You were mentioning kind of deletions in the IGH
locus.
Yeah. Absolutely. So,
thank you for that question. I do not have a great answer for you, but it
does suggest really interesting biology.
My hypothesis is that there are certain B-cell
clones that may be tumor specific,
that may be
aiding the help for the T-cells that we think
are the effectors for checkpoint blockade.
There's a lot of science preclinical models showing that
within the tumor and draining lymph node tissue,
that
there are triads and tetrades of particular immune cells, including
B-cells, T-cells, and antigen-presenting cells that really need to communicate with
each other that predict the
responses to checkpoint blockade. And that's possible that's happening there.
It's purely conjecture,
but the spatial profiling would really help tease that out.
Thank you. Thank you so much.
Okay. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
We'll now move on to our next speaker.
Brings me great pleasure to introduce Enrique Sanz Garcia,
and he will be talking to us about molecular residual disease interception
in local regionally advanced head and neck squamous cell carcinoma, the
MERIDIAN phase two trial.
Dr. Sanz Garcia, the floor is yours.
Good afternoon, everyone.
First of all, I would like to thank on behalf of my co-authors the
opportunity to present the results of the MERIDIAN phase two study, which
evaluates the molecular residual disease interception in patients with locally
advanced head and neck squamous cell carcinoma.
These are my disclosures.
Despite multimodal aggressive therapy, locally advanced head and neck squamous cell
carcinoma is still a very hard disease to treat,
with recurrence rates of around 30% within the first three years.
As in other solid tumors, detection of ctDNA after definitive
therapy has been associated with worse outcomes, as shown by us and
others. For instance, in the pre-MERIDIAN study, which
has paved the way to the study I'm going to present today, we
observed that detection of ctDNA after eight to
12 weeks post-definitive therapy was associated with worse outcomes.
Rivocostimib is a bispecific antibody developed by AstraZeneca
targeting both PD-1 and TIGIT, and at this point is under
investigation in different solid tumors.
We hypothesize that interception with rivocostimib in MRD positive
patients may clear ctDNA, resulting in longer
recurrence-free survival and hopefully include increasing cure rates
in patients with locally advanced head and neck squamous cell carcinoma.
This is the MERIDIAN study design.
This is a phase two, single institution investigator-initiated
trial.
As you can see, all patients were enrolled into part A, where they receive a
standard definitive therapy. In this situation, either
surgery followed by adjuvant therapy, definitive
chemoradiation, or radiation.
Real-time ctDNA analysis was performed during part A and B using
a tumor informed ctDNA assay, RADAAR.
The most important time point was at eight to 12 weeks post the end of definitive
therapy, where this was the one that helped us
to decide whether the patient was MRD positive, provided there was no radiological
or clinical progression.
If eligible, patient will be randomized three to one to receive
six cycles of rivocostimib given every three weeks versus
observation, with real-time ctDNA analysis provided at part C and
the first two time points of part D.
The remaining patients will be enrolled into MRD negative part E,
and they have a retrospective analysis of plasma collected two to six
months at the end of definitive
therapyEligible patients were
patients with squamous cell carcinoma from the oral cavity,
hypopharynx, larynx, and unknown primaries.
We included patients with high risk of recurrence, stage two with radiological
extranodal extension, stage three HPV positive, stage
three, 4A, 4B HPV negative, as well as patients with recurrent
head and neck squamous cell carcinoma that were
treated with curative intent.
Beyond ctDNA detection at the end of part B
and no evidence of clinical and radiological progression, patients should
have a tumor that expressed PD-L1 measured by CPS
equal or more than one.
As previously mentioned, we performed ctDNA analysis on real-time
using RAD assay, which as you may be aware, is a tumor-informed
assay which based on whole exome sequencing of the
tumor can construct patient-specific panels that targets up to
40 variants in plasma.
We also performed some of the samples in a retrospective manner,
including HPV DNA analysis using HPV sequencing
and ultrasensitive next-generation sequencing approach for HPV DNA detection.
And we performed that in all the samples at baseline, as well as on follow-up
samples of patients with oropharyngeal cancer HPV driven.
The primary endpoint of this phase two study was ctDNA clearance in
patients with MRD positivity, defined as no detection of
ctDNA at part D, week two and week 10.
Other endpoints were efficacy, safety, HPV DNA
kinetics, and quality of life and health economics that will be presented in
another
moment.
Our study was designed to include 200 patients in total of three
years, with the assumption that 30% of the patients will be
MRD positive. That will lead to 60 patients and with a
good estimation, with a good power and significant levels to see
difference into both arms.
Recruitment was paused after 52 patients because only two patients
were able to be enrolled into part C and D.
Here are the study disposition of the patients.
Fifty-two patients were screened, and 42 patients were available for
MRD at the end of part B.
Of note, most of the patients were able to have enough tissue to perform
whole exome sequencing. Only three patients didn't have that situation,
and I think that's something to highlight because many of these patients didn't go
into surgery. They were using baseline biopsies, and we were able to construct
that panels properly. The recruitment happened between
July 2023 and June 2025.
These are the study characteristics of the patients enrolled.
These are very similar to any other centers across North America,
mainly oropharyngeal cancer, stage three, and treated with definitive
chemoradiation.
Detection of ctDNA at baseline was observed in
97.4% of the patients where the tumor was in situ, while
concordance between P16 status and HPV DNA in the plasma of
oropharyngeal cancer patients was 96%.
These are the disposition of the patients that were available for
MRD at the end of part B.
Five patients have positive ctDNA, two have equivocal results,
and 35 patients were negative. From those patients who have equivocal
result, one was positive four weeks after the follow-up,
part B follow-up to sample, and another was negative.
From the six patients who were eligible for MRD
positivity, unfortunately, only two could go into part C,
basically because they have radiological disease and one patient
because it was CPS less than one.
However, the patient who underwent treatment is currently free of disease, as I
will show you later, and the patient who went into observation had later
progression.
With a median follow-up of 99.8 months,
there is a total of 10 patients who have, at this moment, recurrence, which is
23% of the evaluable population.
This slide illustrates the journey through the MERIDIAN
study of the patient who received interception therapy, which is patient
17. This patient was diagnosed with a stage three HPV positive
oropharyngeal cancer and was treated with the standard of care chemoradiation.
As you can see in this graph, the ctDNA decreased
significantly post-chemoradiation with a slight increase at the end
of part B, making the patient eligible to undergo
interception because there was no radiological or clinical progression.
The patient received five out of the six planned doses of
plerixafor and the reason why this was stopped earlier it was
because of a grade two tongue pain and neck edema after three cycles of therapy,
leading to the patient to ask for discontinuation of the drug.
However, as you can see in this slide, there is a very nice clearance of
the ctDNA shortly after starting plerixafor,
clearance that persist 12 months after discontinuation of the plerixafor,
and the patient remains disease-free almost two years from the end of the therapy.
Similar kinetics were observed on the patients who
were observed in HPV DNA
analysis.
This is a swimmer plot that tries to show how was the distribution of the
ctDNA analysis in all the patients of the study who were evaluable.
Beyond patient 13, patient 15 have positive
detection of ctDNA across all the time points with increasing rates
and later progression 190 days from the end of
the part B.
Similarly, patient 19, who was not eligible because of
PD-L1 negativity, had a similar situation with progression
235 days.
There is one patient, 31, who was negative at part B
but later was positive during part E and had progression 76
days later. So in these three cases, some lead time from the
detection of ctDNA.Patient 3, 25, and
36 had both ctDNA and
radiological progression at the end of part B.
In contrast, we have a patient, patient eight, who was
negative during part B and had radiological progression at
the end of part B, being a false negative.
Patient 21 and 42 are patients where ctDNA was
not detected during the surveillance and have later progression with a
lead time from the end of part B.
Patient 12 was a patient who had ctDNA
detection four to six weeks after the end of definitive therapy,
but later clear ctDNA with progression two years later.
The only case that was positive during surveillance, it was
patient 40, and the only case that
had a positive result during surveillance and didn't have
radiological progression is patient 40, where there was ctDNA
detection during part E.
However, the follow-up of this patient is still below a year, so we need
further time to see whether this was a false positive or not.
Of note, all the PD samples
that were collected at the time of progression were positive for ctDNA.
We also analyzed whether detection of ctDNA in any of these
time points or in all the time points of surveillance were
associated with recurrence. As you can see here, there is a
clear
correlation between detection of ctDNA and worse outcomes with
a sensitivity of only 50% at the end of part B,
but including longitudinal tracking going up to
73% with a very good specificity at all the time points.
We finally explore whether hpDNA detection in the
subset of patients with oropharyngeal cancer HPV-driven was
associated with worse outcomes. And similar to what we saw
with the RADAR assay, we observed that ctDNA
detection was associated with worse outcomes.
Of note, for both analyses, RADAR and HPV, we excluded patient
17 as this patient had received interception.
But nevertheless, you can see a good sensitivity with a lower specificity
due to a higher number of false positive.
So in conclusion, MERIDIAN is, to our knowledge, the first MRD interception
study in patients with locally advanced head and neck squamous cell carcinoma
post-definitive therapy.
Despite the study was closed, was paused earlier due to a lower than expected
MRD prevalence, the single patient who was randomized to rebirotinib
achieved a ctDNA clearance which is persistent and is currently free of disease
two years later.
Post-treatment ctDNA using RADAR was associated with recurrence, with three cases
having some significant lead time prior to progression.
And despite MRD sensitivity at the follow-up two-time point,
with those eight to 12 weeks after therapy was only 50%, that
improved with serial monitoring.
hpDNA offered higher sensitivity but lower specificity than
RADAR in OPC patients.
Based on these learnings, we have amended the protocol and we have reopened the
protocol using a potentially more sensitive assay with a lower level of
detection, which is the Personal Nex.
We have also included longitudinal tracking similar to IMvigor011,
one time point every three months for the first year, and we have removed
randomization to try to allow more patients to benefit from interception
opportunities.
I would like to thank finally all the study team, especially Dr.
Lilian Siu and Dr. Scott Brahmer for their co-leadership on this trial,
the Princess Margaret Hospital for all the support that it has provided to this,
our collaborators, funders, and most importantly, the patients and
families who have made this possible. Thank you so much.
Thank you very much, Enrique. Do we have any questions?
Maybe I'll start with one.
You highlight some of these cases that were
ctDNA MRD negative, but nonetheless relapsed.
Do you think
is that an opportunity where using one of these genome-wide ultrasensitive
assays with lower limit of detection less than 100 ppm, is that an
opportunity to potentially catch some of those?
Yeah. Thank you so much for that question.
So I think that's one of the reasons mainly.
The assay that we used when we initiated the study was
three years ago. The
technologies have evolved since then.
As I mentioned at the end of my presentation, we are planning to reopen the
MERIDIAN study using a
potential more sensitive assay using whole genome sequencing in the tumor and
tracking up to 1,400 variants, and we are also planning to do some
analysis using other assays of this MERIDIAN cohort.
Another reason, another point I want to highlight is that as you can see, we were
able to detect patients who have a recurrence within a year of the
positive sample. I think it's more difficult to find those who have a recurrence
more than a year, right? And I don't know if those new sensitive assays
are going to be able to catch those patients.
Thank you.
Other questions?
So maybe one more then from me. So I think really
innovative design, and kudos
for that. I guess the question is, knowing what you know now,
if you were to redesign the study,
do you feel that you would still need an observation arm for a
signal-seeking phase two?
So
that's a very good question. Knowing what we know with one only single case,
I wouldn't do that. And indeed, as I also mentioned at the end of my
presentation, we have removed the randomization for the study because
we think that despite it was one case, there are
other trials in other tumor types that we have seen that.
I think we have to give these patients the possibility of interception because we
know that those that are positive, they are going to recur most likely, right?
So we can give them something to avoid that. I think we should do that.
And I am totally in favor of removing randomization in these kind of studies.
I have one last question. Kind
of-When thinking about HPV positive head and
neck cancer patients, is there
an opportunity to think of them a little bit differently?
Meaning that you have HPV as an additional biomarker and then
you have some fundamental differences in biology as well.
Could you try to combine both radar and HPV and
bolster the performance of the assay there?
So I couldn't present this, but hopefully we can present that in another
moment. But basically, we saw that when we combine OPC
patients both a tumor-informed assay and the HPV DNA, we
increase sensitivity to 100%. However, we
reduce specificity.
And we are using a very
new way of measuring the HPV DNA, which is HPV
sequencing. That's based on the pre-median that we saw that it was better than
digital PCR. But I think we have to tune down a little bit our assay to try to make
sure that we have both specific and sensitive.
Thank you very much, Enrique. Thank you very much.
Okay. Our next presenter is
Li Lu. He'll be presenting on unlocking endocrine resistance,
co-targeting KAT6 and ER with
bifetostat,
PF-07248144, which is easier to say,
and fulvestrant drives tumor and ctDNA response in
ER-positive, HER2-negative metastatic breast cancer.
Thank you so much for the introduction.
So good afternoon, everyone.
On behalf of all my co-authors,
I'm pleased to present our abstract,
co-targeting KAS6 and ER with bifetostat and
fulvestrant in ER-positive, HER2-negative metastatic
breast cancer.
Here is my disclosure.
So bifetostat is a first-in-class potent and
selective small molecule inhibitor of both
KAS6A and 6B, two of the epigenetic
modifiers that regulate oncogenic transcriptome
programs.
In the Phase one study, bifetostat has demonstrated a
tolerable safety profile and durable anti-tumor activity,
especially when combined with fulvestrant in
ER-positive, HER2-negative metastatic breast cancer.
Based on PK/PD safety and anti-tumor
activity, bifetostat five milligram once daily
dosing plus fulvestrant was identified as the
recommended dose for the ongoing Phase three
KAS6-1 study.
Here we report how we use exploratory
pharmacodynamic markers of
KAS6 inhibition on tumor gene expression and also
using early ctDNA changes to further support Phase three
dose selection and also further elucidate this
novel mechanism of action.
So this is a first in human study, evaluate
bifetostat as monotherapy and in combination
with fulvestrant in heavily pretreated
ER-positive, HER2-negative metastatic breast cancer.
So I will focus on the three dose optimization groups,
including bifetostat at five milligram
monotherapy and compare one and five
milligram in combination with fulvestrant.
Our biomarker objectives was to explore
tumor and ctDNA changes to further support the Phase three dose
selection and help us to understand the mechanism.
Just a quick definition for the patient populations.
ITT include all patients who receive at
least one dose of treatment.
For the ctDNA biomarkers subpopulation
include all patients with ctDNA changes with
nine weeks of treatment from baseline.
So now let's first review the patient populations.
Overall, baseline demographics and the prior line of
therapies were similar across and between ITT and
ctDNA cohorts.
It is worth to note that every patient in the study received the
prior CDK four/six inhibitor plus endocrine therapy.
In terms of sample size, the ctDNA
cohorts included seventy to eighty percent of the
ITT population in each of those groups.
In terms of biomarker sample, we collect a serial
PBMC tumor pair biopsy samples at baseline and
on cycle one day fifteen and ctDNA plasma
samples before and after treatment.
Serving as a KAS6 target engagement, the
H3K23 acetylation marker was evaluated
in both PBMC and in paired tumor biopsy
samples.
We also use the same pair biopsy sample profile for
tumor gene expression.
We apply simple linear model, look at the log two fold of change
for single gene and the gene signature expression
analysis. P-value was calculated based on the pooled
variance across those cohort.
ctDNA mutation burden and variant allele frequency for
each individual gene were assessed with the Guardant74 Gene
Panel Assay.ctDNA clearance was defined
as a change from detectable of the ctDNA mutation burden
at baseline T1 to nondetectable at T2, and
T2 was cycle three, day one, which occur on week nine.
If sample is not available, then any sample within nine weeks of
treatment.
Now I'll move to results.
Here we are looking at the CAS6 target engagement data.
Patients who received profatrexstat at one and five milligram
monotherapy and in combination with favoraltrutol
achieved at least 50% reduction of
H3K23 acetylation in both PBMC,
which is on your left,
and also in tumor pair biopsy samples, confirming
the strong and robust CAS6 target inhibition.
So in order to understand more about the mechanism of action, we also
evaluate tumor gene expression changes at cycle one, day
15 from baseline.
Across the treatment groups, profatrexstat at five milligram
plus favoraltrutol demonstrate the most consistent
and strong gene expression changes.
As you can see here in the heat map, the genes
that go up are labeled as red, and the
genes go down are showing in blue.
So profatrexstat at five milligram plus favoraltrutol increase the
number of tumor suppressor genes such as FOXP3,
ING4, and also decrease key
cell cycle genes including TK1,
CYCB1, CYCE1, et cetera,
as well as ER responsive gene TFF3.
This data suggests that profatrexstat at five milligram
plus favoraltrutol is more effective to block
CAS6 and ER signaling in tumor microenvironment,
support the mechanistic link between the epigenetic
modification and the anti-tumor activity.
To link these findings to the anti-tumor activities
observed, we assess next if we can use
early ctDNA clearance to distinguish those dose
levels and regimens.
In the ctDNA change evaluable patients,
profatrexstat at five milligram plus favoraltrutol
demonstrate the most pronounced early ctDNA clearance.
The clearance rates was 26.5%
for the overall ctDNA and
63% for ESR1 mutation and
31% for PI3K pathway gene mutations,
including PIK3CA, AKT1, and PTEN
genes.
In contrast, we observed much less ctDNA
clearance in the low dose one milligram plus favoraltrutol
and the five milligram monotherapy patients.
So this data further support that profatrexstat at five
milligram plus favoraltrutol is the optimal dose move
forward to phase three.
Now with the optimal dose, profatrexstat five milligram
plus favoraltrutol also demonstrate early ctDNA
clearance in association with clinical response.
Here is the heat map showing every patient their
ctDNA change.
Bottom is the baseline mutation status for ESR1
and PI3K pathway genes.
And you can see from the figure,
patient who achieve ctDNA clearance, labeled as the
star, and deep reduction of ctDNA tend to be
associated with better clinical outcome,
particularly with the patient who achieve partial response
and stable disease. This relationship was seen
regardless of baseline mutation status for
ESR1 and PI3K pathway genes,
consistent with the broad anti-tumor activities observed.
Not only the early ctDNA clearance associated with
clinical response, we also observed that patient with
non-detect ctDNA within nine weeks of treatment had a
numeric longer PFS compared with those with detectable
ctDNA.
As shown in the Kaplan-Meier curve, the median PFS
was 21.9 months for the patient who had a
non-detectable ctDNA or ctDNA negative within nine weeks of
treatment, whereas only 5.3 months for
the patient who had
ctDNA detectable or positive
still retained within nine weeks of treatment.
To conclude,
profatrexstat five milligram plus favoraltrutol demonstrate
meaningful pharmacodynamic changes by shifting
tumors toward tumor suppressor programs and
away from cell cycle progression and ER-driven
transcription.
This regimen also shows early ctDNA clearance,
including robust clearance of ESR1
variants and most of these variants associated with
endocrine resistance,
this early molecular response associated with clinical anti-tumor
activity.
Taken together,
this data support profatrexstat five milligram plus
favoraltrutol as the recommended dose and the regimen
for the ongoing phase three CAS6-1 study.
More broadly,
integrate tumor and ctDNA biomarkers can
provide complementary molecular
insightsFor this case, for co-targeting CAS6 and
ER, and they enable phase three dose selection and the molecular
response monitoring, especially in early drug development
programs.
Limitations include a ctDNA analysis
constrained by small sample size and limited time points.
Expanded longitudinal profiling
will be addressed in the pivotal phase three studies.
With that, I would like to thank all patients, investigators,
and study teams. Thank you for your attention.
Okay. We'll open it up for questions.
I could start with one. I think this is a great
example to see these compelling waterfall plots on the ctDNA,
which really, I think, helps instill a sense of activity with
those stable disease patients.
Mm-hmm.
Maybe could you comment on your perspectives on those few PD
patients? And granted, you didn't have many.
Yeah, no this-
But I can see that three of those five had more than a 50% drop in the
ctDNA despite being progressors. Any comments on that or how to interpret?
Yeah. So we actually are working out to understand the
determinants of the responder versus non-responders,
and this ctDNA profiling ongoing, we
are trying to use these patients to generate some hypothesis,
then also further test in the phase three.
Because phase one is a small sample size, but give us hint.
So this analysis is ongoing. We will
share in the future meetings or publications.
Yeah, really an excellent talk.
The question I have is,
tell us about how you see the future in terms of how
we can incorporate ctDNA clearance into phase one trials for dose
finding like you've done here. Do you see this as something that could be
generalizable?
I think that this becomes more and more
useful tool for help us understand
how the drug response, how early on.
But phase one, we have to
know that patients are more heterogeneous.
So
with the tumor,
radiographic assessment is very important, but ctDNA provide
another parameter, give us more confidence, I would say.
Predictions still, I think we need to understand more, but add the
value to provide more confidence so decisions can be
made if both are showing in the right direction.
So I think it gives the confidence to make decisions.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
So it brings me great pleasure to introduce our next speaker, Dr.
Gozde Kar. And her talk is titled
"ctDNA Clearance as a Prognostic Biomarker in
Extensive Stage Small Cell Lung Cancer:
Insights from the LUMINOUS Phase 3B Study."
Dr. Kar, the floor is yours.
Thank you so much for the introduction.
These are my disclosures.
Immune checkpoint inhibitors combined with chemotherapy have become the
first-line standard of care for extensive stage small cell lung
cancer.
Here we have phase 3B LUMINOUS study, which evaluated
first-line durvalumab plus up to six cycles of platinum
etoposide in patients with extensive stage small cell lung cancer.
In the final results, median PFS was six point three months.
Median OS was sixteen point four months,
and the results were consistent with the CASPIAN study, which is phase
three trial
comparing durvalumab plus platinum etoposide versus
platinum etoposide.
Despite the advances in treatment with immunochemotherapy,
only a minority of patients derive long-term survival benefits.
Therefore, a marker for evaluating early signal
for cancer recurrence will be valuable.
Changes in ctDNA during treatment are emerging as a potential
tool for monitoring outcomes.
And here we assess ctDNA clearance as a dynamic biomarker
to predict survival outcomes and recurrence risk in the LUMINOUS
study.
LUMINOUS is a phase 3B single-arm multicenter
international study that enrolled one hundred and fifty-two
patients.
Patients were treated with durvalumab plus platinum
etoposide every three weeks for four to six cycles,
followed by the durvalumab every four weeks until disease
progression.
Plasma samples for the ctDNA were collected at
predose up to six cycles, and then at
maintenance start
at each tumor assessment thereafter and at disease
progression.
For assessment of ctDNA detection, clearance, and
tumor burden longitudinally, we used GRAIL
Portrait RIO assay which is a tumor-agnostic,
methylation-based ctDNA assay.
All the patients who had baseline samples had
detectable ctDNA at baseline. Here we
show the tumor methylated fraction for individual patients
across the time points, and the points are
colored by ctDNA detected or not detected as
defined by the GRAIL algorithm.
So we observed that ctDNA detection and level of tumor
methylated fraction decreased during treatmentAnd
at cycle two, we observe 89% of ctDNA
detection, and at maintenance start, we observe
46% of ctDNA detection.
Then we define the clearance rate as the proportion of
patients who are showing ctDNA clearance.
It is shown in the plots and the table here.
At the maintenance start, 54% of the patients show
ctDNA clearance, and at third tumor
assessment, 67% of the patients showed
ctDNA clearance, although the sample size
at this time point is small.
ctDNA clearance from baseline to cycle two was
associated with longer overall survival.
And for the clearance group, median OS was not reached.
For the non-clearance group, median OS was 16.4
months. And on the right-hand side, we show that
ctDNA clearance is also associated with progression-free
survival. Median PFS for the
clearance group is 19.3 months compared to
6.2 months for the non-clearance group.
The patients who achieved early sustained ctDNA
clearance was associated with the most favorable
survival outcome.
And the patients that show late clearance, meaning
that they had positive ctDNA at cycle two and
then they become negative at maintenance start period,
denoted here as late clearance, they had the intermediate
outcomes. And the patients never cleared, they are
showing the poorest survival outcomes.
When we incorporate an additional time point coinciding with
the tumor assessment one,
we observed that the patients who showed early and
sustained clearance, they had the most favorable
outcome. And the patients who were
ctDNA negative at a earlier time point but then
relapsed at a later time point, they are showing the
intermediate outcomes.
And the patients, again, never cleared, they are showing the poorest
survival outcomes.
Then we look at the individual patient ctDNA
dynamics, alongside with RECIST tumor
assessments. And here we see the profiles from individual
patients that are representative of clearance groupings that I
mentioned.
So we observed that ctDNA dynamics aligns with the
longitudinal tumor assessments and the clinical response.
For the sustained clearance patients shown on the left-hand side,
sustained clearance reflected the decrease in target
lesion size, and this patient was partial
responder.
And for the patient that was ctDNA negative in the
beginning but then become relapsed, that is
shown in the middle panel here,
ctDNA re-emergence occurred 55 days
before the clinical progression.
And for the patient never cleared, there was
ctDNA increase 150 days before the clinical
progression.
There was a decrease in the
target lesion for the never cleared patient, consistent with
the partial response in the primary tumor, but
then the patient developed a brain metastasis, so it
was shown as the PD by the investigator.
So with ctDNA, we were able to
detect this before the clinical progression.
Here we show survival and clinical response
for individual patients for the ctDNA status groups.
Never cleared, relapsed, and the sustained clearance groups.
Sustained clearance patients, all of them were alive at the 12th
month
compared to 82% of the relapse group
and 36% of the never cleared group.
And only 22% of the sustained clearance patients
developed disease progression within nine months
compared to 59% of the relapse and
89% of the never cleared group.
In conclusion, this exploratory analysis showed that
ctDNA clearance using the tumor-agnostic
methylation assay may be prognostic in patients with
extensive stage small cell lung cancer receiving first-line
durvalumab with platinum etoposide.
And the patterns of clearance over time were strongly
linked to overall survival and progression-free
survival, highlighting the ctDNA clearance as a
meaningful biomarker.
And the results are consistent with other studies in small cell lung
cancer.
Changes in ctDNA status during treatment may serve as a
surrogate for progression and survival outcomes.
To further support the use of ctDNA for clinical
decisions, we need additional datasets showing the
correlation of clinical outcomes and ctDNA dynamics.
And ctDNA may complement other biomarker strategies to
guide precision therapy, disease monitoring, and especially
understanding the resistance mechanisms in extensive-stage small
cell lung cancer.
On behalf of my co-authors, we express special gratitude
to Filippo De Marinis, who was director at the European
Institute of Oncology, who made significant contribution to study
and sadly passed away this year.We would also like to thank
the patients, their families, and caregivers, as well as the
investigators and site personnel, and the LUMINA study team.
So if you want to obtain a copy of the slides, please scan the
QR code shown here. Thank you for your attention.
Excellent talk, Gozde. Thank you so much. Any questions?
We'll start here with the first question, kind of on my left
side.
Oh,
maybe I'll start with one, actually.
So,
it's a great talk, and it's very interesting that I think so far all the talks
we've been hearing have used tumor-informed ultrasensitive assays.
This one used a tumor-naive, methylation-based assay.
Can you comment on that?
Yes. For the LUMINA study, we only have tumor biopsies
from the baseline samples.
And of course, due to tissue limited
availability,
it is not easy to obtain tissue for the tumor-informed assay.
So that's why we went on with the liquid biopsies,
and
so we can assess longitudinal time points.
Excellent. Thank you.
Maybe I'll follow up on that with an assay question.
So I understand that you can quantify the tumor
methylation fraction. My understanding was when it fell below a certain
threshold, then it was called ctDNA negative, even though it was still
quantifiable, correct?
Yes.
Yes. Okay. And is that threshold
set by study, or is it a tumor type specific
threshold, or is it a uniform threshold for the assay?
Yeah, it is defined by the GRAIL platform, actually.
So they have these showing the tumor-methylated fractions,
and using the machine learning algorithm, it is either
ctDNA detected or not detected based on the machine learning,
or based on a large database of methylation
patterns of different tumors.
So it's actually not a threshold, it's just whether the machine learning flagged it
as-
Yes
... as detectable or not. Okay.
Very good, thank you. Please.
Great talk. Thank you for sharing that.
You mentioned in your conclusions about additional data sets that would be helping
to help guide this work further. What data sets did you have in
mind?
So, well, additional data sets to replicate and of
course validate the clinical findings, but
also in terms of the clinical utility, I think we also
require prospective randomized trials
that are showing the ctDNA guided versus standard
care, so we can really understand the
efficiency of the ctDNA as a biomarker in clinic.
Great. Thank you.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
Maybe I'll ask one more. Have you
thought about going into other...
There's so much happening in small cell lung cancer, including
the drug tarlatamab. Are you thinking about utilizing this sort of
ctDNA clearance technology in those settings as well?
Yes. You mean the small cell lung cancer-
Yeah
... specifically?
Yep.
Yes. We have other
studies that are looking at the more tumor-informed assays
and looking at the
ctDNA data in the other small cell studies.
And maybe one last question. So in this sort of
methylation-based tumor-naive assay, are certain
cancers like small cell lung cancer that we know have higher mutant
allele fractions, just higher overall ctDNA levels, are
they more amenable to these tumor-naive assays
compared to, let's say, lower SHAD malignancies?
Yeah, for the small cell, there is a high shedding, so it is
more likely to capture ctDNA-
Mm-hmm
... by even the tumor-methylated fractions.
So-
Thank you. Thank you again, Dr. Kar.
Excellent job. Really appreciate it.
Okay. I'd like to introduce our
final speaker for the session, Janet Markman, who's going to be presenting
on "ctDNA as a Prognostic and Pharmacodynamic
Biomarker Following First or Later Line Treatment of Advanced
Non-Small Cell Lung Cancer with BNT116 and
Cemiplimab." Dr. Markman.
Thank you for the introduction.
It's my pleasure to present this talk today titled, "ctDNA as a
Prognostic and Pharmacodynamic Biomarker Following First or Later Line
Treatment of Advanced NSCLC with BNT116 plus Cemiplimab"
on behalf of my co-authors and the LeucaMerit1 trial investigators.
Here are my disclosures.
BNT116 is an investigational
cancer immunotherapy developed by BioNTech as part of its FixVax
platform. It consists of a fixed combination of six
tumor-associated antigens, as shown on the left, that are frequently
expressed in NSCLC.
These TAAs are encoded on mRNA
uridine-based
mRNAs that are formulated into lipoplexes and are
injected intravenously and preferentially delivered to lymphoid
resident antigen-presenting cells, which mature upon exposure.
BNT116 induces an innate interferon type I
response that is mediated by Toll-like
receptorsAnd results in DC maturation and
induction of antigen-specific T cell responses.
The differentiation and expansion of naive T cells
is associated with the immune checkpoint
regulatory molecule PD-1. Thus, by combining
BNT116 with cemiplimab, a PD-1 inhibitor, we expect
synergistic anti-tumor effects.
LEUCA-MERIT1 is an ongoing Phase 1 trial aimed to explore the
safety and clinical activity of BNT116 as a
monotherapy or in combination with multiple therapies for
advanced NSCLC.
Here we present clinical and ctDNA data from patients who
received BNT116 plus cemiplimab in cohorts one, two, and four.
Cohort one patients were heavily pre-treated.
To be eligible for the addition of cemiplimab, patients had to have a
tumor PD-L1 expression of greater than or equal to 1% and had to be
able to tolerate additional PD-1 therapy.
Here we're only showing the 13 patients that had the optional cemiplimab
treatment.
Patients in cohort two had prior progression on PD-L1
or PD-1 inhibitors and had tumor PD-L1 expression greater
than or equal to 1%.
Patients in cohort four were frail patients who were not candidates for
first-line chemotherapy as assessed by the investigator due
to reasons such as age or comorbidities and had PD-L1 expression greater
than or equal to 1%. The endpoints were consistent across the three
cohorts and included safety, tolerability, measures of clinical
efficacy,
as well as biomarkers.
BNT116 was administered with an initial priming schedule of seven
weekly vaccinations, followed by a maintenance schedule of vaccinations once
every three weeks.
Cemiplimab was administered once every three weeks, starting at cycle three for
patients in cohort one and at cycle
one, day one for patients in cohorts two and four.
Cell-free DNA was collected longitudinally at every cycle for cycles one through
five, at cycle seven, cycle nine, every third cycle thereafter,
plus at the end of therapy and the end of follow-up for ctDNA assessment.
We used a tumor agnostic NGS hybrid capture panel targeting
197 cancer-related genes and used the matched
genomic DNA from buffy coat to filter out CHIP
variants.
MR50 and MR100 were defined as least a 50%
or 100% reduction in ctDNA from baseline based on max
VAF. The ctDNA status and the VAF of somatic variants
were estimated as a surrogate of tumor burden and to correlate ctDNA
dynamics with clinical outcomes.
Clinically,
here we show the baseline characteristics.
By design, the major differences in these cohorts were the requirement for PD-L1
expression,
which was highest in cohort two, and the number of median prior lines of therapy,
which was zero in cohort four, one in cohort two, and
three in cohort one.
Clinically, we saw that patients in cohort one had disease
control rates of 62%, while in cohort
two, 80% of patients had disease control, including one complete
response, and 75% patients in cohort four.
The median overall survival was 23 months or more across all three
cohorts. PFS was nearly three months in cohort one,
6.2 months in cohort two... or 5.5 months in cohort two, and
11.6 months in cohort four, while duration of disease control was
12.8, 6.2, and 12.5 months in cohort four.
Overall, BNT116 plus cemiplimab demonstrated clinical activity
in patients with advanced NSCLC.
We assessed associations between ctDNA levels at baseline and changes during
treatment with clinical responses.
First, we looked at efficacy outcomes dichotomized by baseline ctDNA
levels above, as shown in purple, or below, as shown in green, the
median max VAF. All tables include a
95% confidence interval for median time to event estimates.
Here we show that patients that had lower ctDNA levels at treatment
start had improved overall survival and progression-free survival, but not
duration of disease control, following treatment with BNT116 plus
cemiplimab.
Second, we looked at efficacy outcomes by baseline ctDNA status.
Patients were split into subgroups according to having undetectable levels at
baseline, as shown in green, or detectable ctDNA, as shown in purple.
Overall, 12 out of 51, or 24% of patients, had
undetectable levels at baseline.
These patients had improved overall survival and a trend towards increased
progression-free survival following treatments with BNT116 plus cemiplimab.
Next, we investigated the time to achieve at least a 50% reduction in
ctDNA and the associated radiological responses.
We see the best change of target lesions from baseline, shown in the waterfall
plots on the top, as well as the changes over time, shown in the
corresponding spider plots on the bottom,
colored by the best changes of ctDNA within cycles two,
three, and four.
As evidenced, shown in light green, the decrease of ctDNA in
patients achieving at least a 50% reduction occurs as early as cycle two,
day one, as shown on the left, which is post three vaccinations and one
cycle of cemiplimab.
All patients that achieved at least a partial response had a molecular
response of 50% or more by cycle four, day one, as shown on the right.
Thus, a greater than or equal to 50% reduction in ctDNA from cycle one, day
one occurred early after receiving BNT116 plus cemiplimab and
was associated with durable reduction in tumor size, as evidenced in the
corresponding spider plots.
Finally, we looked at efficacy outcomes by best change in
ctDNA.Patients that had undetectable ctDNA levels
at all time points are depicted in green.
Patients that had a full clearance of ctDNA or a molecular response of
100% at any time point are shown in orange.
Patients that achieved a molecular response of 50%, but did not achieve
full clearance are shown in light green, and patients that were
non-molecular responders, which includes those that either didn't have a
reduction of 50%, had no change in ctDNA, or had an
increase in ctDNA, are shown in
purple. Overall,
13 out of 49 patients or 27%
achieved ctDNA clearance at any time point.
And importantly, these patients had similar outcomes to those with
undetectable ctDNA at all assessed time points.
In conclusion, BNT116 plus cemiplimab demonstrated
intriguing clinical activity in patients with advanced NSCLC.
Overall, approximately 20% of patients had undetectable ctDNA at all
time points, while over 40% achieved at least a molecular response
within three to nine weeks of BNT116 plus cemiplimab treatment,
and 27% of patients achieving a full ctDNA
clearance.
The molecular responses after BNT116 plus cemiplimab treatment were
associated with clinical outcomes in patients with advanced NSCLC.
Patients who achieved ctDNA clearance had similar outcomes to those with
undetectable ctDNA at all assessed time points.
These findings support the use of ctDNA as a potential efficacy surrogate
in clinical trials, offering a potential path to accelerate therapy
development and underscoring the need to further
investigation.
I would like to thank my co-authors,
importantly, the patients and their families, the meeting organizers, and the
staff, research coordinators, and investigators of each participating
institution. Thank you, and I'm happy to take your questions.
Okay, open for questions.
Okay, I'll just note that if you did have a question
online, the system is down at the moment, so please come up to
the mic please. Yes.
Great talk and thank you for taking us through the data.
I noticed that
you had a portion of patients that didn't have any ctDNA
detectable,
and in those patients,
they seem to have an overall survival that was equivalent to the ones that
had clearance. But when you looked at the PFS curves, it
seems that the outcomes were worse.
So does that suggest that those patients
either had tumors that weren't shedding or
we weren't able to detect, or were the assays limitations?
How would you explain that?
Yeah, I think we're dealing with very small patient numbers here, and we
are using a tumor-agnostic approach.
So probably these are advanced NSCLC patients.
So I would imagine if we were using a tumor-informed approach, we'd
probably have more of that 100% detection rate.
So I think it's a little bit difficult to answer that question.
Thank you.
Scott, please.
Very exciting data. Some cell-free DNA technologies can
also measure T-cell receptor complexity,
and that could be done, I guess, in conjunction with the ctDNA kinetics.
Is that something that you're planning on exploring
and that there could be additional utility?
Yeah, so we do
have a subset of patients where we're collecting PBMCs.
So we're looking at these tumor-specific responses, the antigen-specific
responses, and then we are planning to do a subset of TCR-seq on the patients that
we have these available cells. We just haven't done it yet.
And do you think that plasma TCR
sequences could also be complementary in addition to PBMCs?
Have you looked at that?
I'm sorry, could you repeat that?
Within the cell-free DNA, in addition to PBMCs, I'm
curious.
Yeah, I don't know that we have the samples to answer that question.
Okay.
Another question over here.
Yeah, that was a nice talk. Have you correlated the patients with stable disease
and ctDNA clearance with PFS assessments?
Because I guess one could say that the resist assessments
might correlate with your PFS-OS.
That's what resist is supposed to do.
So I guess the ctDNA assessments might give you the more insights in those patients
with stable disease. Have you looked at that?
Yeah, we'd have to look at that separately.
These patients that achieve these stable diseases, they're really, really
long-term. So we know at least these are really
sustainable stable disease responses.
Whether those patients had ctDNA clearance or not, I'd have to double-check and
look at that specifically.
Thanks.
Okay.
Very good. Well, thank you very much.
Thank you.
Okay.
Now I'd like to turn it over to my co-chair for his closing remarks.
Thank
you.
Thank you very much.
What an excellent session.
I think we went through just a diversity of different studies, different disease
types, different ctDNA technologies,
different
questions, different sampling strategies,
different sort of longitudinal approaches.
So these are my disclosures.
And so kind of as I was trying to think about how to
tie this up, I really see that the field has been moving.
The ctDNA MRD field has been moving from detection to dynamics, and
then hopefully now integration into these clinical trial settings and
ultimately decision makingAnd with modern technology,
namely these modern ultrasensitive ctDNA technologies, whether
they be tumor-informed, whole genome based, or whole exome
based, or methylation based tumor-naive
technologies. With modern technology, now rigorous trial frameworks
like we saw today, ctDNA is moving from
what was once seen as a static biomarker, kind of a
one-time assessment, a few months after treatment completion, to now
longitudinal biological signal.
We're really seeing the power of the
kinetics and the dynamics and the insight that that's giving us.
We're
moving from prognostic to predictive and actionable.
I think this
move has been slower than a lot of us
expected, but we are moving clearly in that direction, and that was
highlighted today.
And we're moving from just purely tumor burden to treatment
response biology. We're getting greater biological insight
beyond just kind of the level of the residual disease.
But we need to develop some of these biological axes further,
and as we delve deeper, and these are beginning to emerge.
So timing of detection, what is the meaning of early versus late
ctDNA MRD?
What does that mean from a patient outcome standpoint?
What does that mean biologically? The depth of detection.
Now that we have these ultrasensitive technologies, we can query the
differences between a patient who is detected at low level versus an ultra
low level. What is the meaning of that clinically and biologically?
And the trajectory, we really saw just the power of dynamics,
kinetics, and clearance patterns today.
So these were the seven studies that we went over today.
We went through studies
on breast cancer, head and neck cancer, non-small cell lung cancer, small cell
lung cancer,
colorectal cancer, inflammatory breast cancer.
Different modalities going from novel epigenetic
therapies, mRNA vaccines, immunotherapy,
chemotherapy,
neoadjuvant IO, adjuvant IO, and we also looked at
different roles that ctDNA played in these different studies,
going from dose selection, response assessment,
MRD detection. We saw kind of the frameworks for
interventional studies, molecular response, prognostication,
clearance, kinetics.
I'm going to take you through some of these studies, just one slide from each one
that I found really compelling. So this beautiful study on
epigenetic modulation in breast
cancer
combined with fulvestrant. So
really kind of showing how ctDNA clearance could in the
future be used for these dose finding studies, and we're seeing a very clear
difference in the ctDNA clearance rates as we go from
monotherapy to a lower dose with fulvestrant to a higher dose of
fulvestrant.
Head and neck squamous cell carcinoma, the MERIDIAN study, really a beautiful study
design, and I love how the investigators challenged themselves to
go beyond correlation and start going directly
towards interception. Can we take the MRD positive patients
and intervene with an investigational agent?
Their accrual was modest, but I think kudos to the
investigators for really taking this leap which is critical
for our field.
Non-small cell lung cancer treated with an mRNA
vaccine. Very interesting seeing just
how these different response patterns are correlating with outcomes using
a tumor-naive assay, a very practical hybrid capture based
tumor-naive assay.
Small cell lung cancer using another tumor-naive methylation
based assay, and quite a sensitive one, really showing the differences
in patterns of relapse based on patterns of
ctDNA clearance. The patients who never cleared,
they did the worst, unfortunately.
The patients who achieved sustained clearance, they did quite well, and for small
cell lung cancer, this is very impressive, and the patients with late clearance,
they were intermediate.
And then in breast cancer, the MONITOR study, the patients with
pathological complete response did
extremely well. Patients, they
achieved ctDNA negativity. There was some
negativity also in the patients who had residual disease, so that
kind of further highlights that maybe single
time point approaches are not enough for
predicting pathological complete response.
But the investigators showed here the power of dynamics
with repeat kinetic sampling, they're able to further boost
the sensitivity of the approach, and our breast cancer colleagues are really
showing that ctDNA MRD adds another
lens beyond path CR and might really highlight some patients
who are doing well, even if they have some residual disease remaining,
but the ctDNA MRD is negative.
And then this really nice study in colorectal cancer, the NEOPRISM study, the
patients who are super molecular responders, they did exceptionally
well. They achieved pathological complete
responses. The ones who had dynamic molecular
responses with a rapid reduction, they by and large had
pathological complete responses, and the poor molecular responders didn't have path
CRs, really kind of taking us towards this new avenue of
non-operative management in this disease type and setting.
And then inflammatory breast cancer, really again seeing the importance
of serial sampling using this ultrasensitive assay
from Myriad Genetics showing that the different
patterns of ctDNA, how that's correlating with
response outcomes, survival outcomes, and ultimately relapse.
So some take home messages that I took away from this
really exceptionally
compelling session was that with ultrasensitive technology,
ctDNA MRD has evolved from a static
biomarker. When I got into this field, that's how I saw it, saw it as a
single time point at the first follow-up visit
for my patients to now a dynamic framework for treatment
response assessment.
We of course need to continue to push the envelope towards predictive and
actionable study designs like MERIDIAN
as we move ctDNA MRD beyond a prognostic and
correlative biomarker to facilitate clear clinical utility
across disease and therapeutic settings.
And finally, I think we learned a lot about biology and really the
next frontier of biology
in the studies today, and kind of as we're getting this
greater insight, can we turn that biology into even
additional actionable thresholds beyond detection, also
incorporating kinetics
to enable further personalization of MRD
guided clinical decision making in the future.
So thank you very much and hope you guys had a good session. Thank you.